[Musique]
chaque semaine André Vigier monte dans
la tour du Parlement pour huiler le
mécanisme de l'horloge cette Léna
porter chez nous à rester à l'Assemblée
nationale
[Musique]
même si les règles le cadran au corps de
tour de puits 35 ans
[Musique]
c'est la première fois je voyais ça là
il a l'impression que le temps s'est
arrêté durant la pandémie
ici tout semblait figé personne dans les
couloirs aucun visiteur ni employé pas
même un député pour faire avancer les
travaux parlementaires c'est leur qu'on
peut comprendre le temps comment il est
important à sa mère
j'ai pris la décision de fermer toutes
les entreprises et tous les commerces
[Musique]
rien ne laissait présager que François
Legault aurait à gérer l'une des pires
crises de l'histoire du Québec au
pouvoir pour la première fois la cacerie
de surplus enviable 8 milliards de
dollars qui lui permettent de réduire la
taxe scolaire bonifier les allocations
familiales rétablir le tarif unique dans
les garderies et la gratuité de la
fécondation in vitro moi je vais être
très semblable
pourtant sa position sur l'immigration
divise il veut réduire le seuil annuel à
40 000 nouveaux arrivants qui doivent
maintenant passer un test des valeurs
québécoises les dossiers de 18000
d'entre eux seront éliminés pour
permettre au gouvernement de repartir le
processus sur de nouvelles bases on est
capable au Québec de débattre d'une
question importante comme celle-là le
débat s'enflamme quand la loi sur la
laisse et déposée le gouvernement
fidèle le choix de discriminer les
Québécoises de confession musulmane la
loi interdit le port de signe religieux
pour les enseignants les agents de la
paix les juges et les procureurs de la
Couronne on n'a pas besoin de signes
religieux pour personnes pour éviter les
contestations judiciaires le
gouvernement recourt à la clause
dérogatoire ce qui ouvre un nouveau
front de discorde avec Ottawa
utilisation de la clause nonobstant ne
devrait être fait quand des moments
exceptionnels Québec utilisera cette
clause deux fois plus tôt qu'une bonjour
la deuxième fois pour sa réforme de la
loi 101 loi sur la langue officielle et
commune du Québec est adopté
les anglophones trouvent que le Parti
libéral ne les défend pas ce qui force
la chef Dominique Anglade à se
reconnecter avec sa base tu allais à la
rencontre des gens d'autant plus que son
virage progressiste dérange couronné
sans course à la direction après le
désistement de son seul adversaire elle
veut renouveler en prenant ses distances
de Philippe Couillard et jean-charrey
j'ai jamais dit que ce serait facile non
plus d'opérer un tel virage aujourd'hui
je vais faire un appel un appel à la
solidarité et pendant ce temps François
Legault prend toute la visibilité
l'urgence sanitaire renouvelé une
centaine de fois durant la pandémie lui
donne des pouvoirs exceptionnels on doit
prendre des décisions difficiles le défi
28 jours l'annulation de Noël le
passeport vaccinal il couvre-feu la
fermeture des salles de spectacle des
jims des commerces des écoles
parce que j'ai des amis j'ai une super
prof
les problèmes de santé mentale se gèrent
difficilement les recules sur la
vaccination obligatoire des travailleurs
de la santé sur la taxe pour les non
vaccinés rien de tout ça n'est pire que
les catons du CHSLD
[Musique]
aujourd'hui le Québec se souvient on
compte plus de 16000 décès au Québec
nous sommes nous pas rendus à déclencher
une enquête publique
après celle de la Commissaire à la santé
de la vérificatrice générale et de la
protectrice du citoyen je pense que
Christian a un approche un peu plus
cassant devant le quasi effondrement du
réseau il écarte Daniel mecane pour
Christian Dubé dont le plan doit faire
ses preuves trouver un médecin de
famille pour chaque Québécois couper un
milliard de dollars dans le salaire des
médecins spécialistes et abolir le temps
supplémentaire obligatoire des
infirmières s'avèrent irréalisable les
crises permettent aux organisations de
se repenser même si la campagne de
vaccination est un succès elle ne
sauvera pas le poste du docteur Horacio
à Ruda le mieux c'est de l'eau plus de
savon véritable vedette au début de la
pandémie avec sa candeur et ses
tartelettes
le Premier ministre doit s'en débarquer
ses décisions sont fortement critiquées
j'ai des menaces de mort je reçois des
courriels injurieux tous les jours les
députés de tous les partis sont aussi
menacés la sécurité est rehaussée c'est
important qu'on soit ensemble de parler
à l'unisson par solidarité on est unis
au plus fort de la pandémie la partie
zannerie n'existe plus mais la politique
reprend vite ses droits durant l'année
pré électorale François Legault est
associé à la Grande Noirceur sa
meilleure imitation de Maurice Duplessis
l'ancien leader étudiant Gabriel Nadaud
Dubois prend du galon à Québec solidaire
Manon masser lui cède sa place de chef
parlementaire François Legault fait de
lui son adversaire
il manque d'attention l'attention se
porte surtout sur la députée Catherine
Dorion au début du mandat pour son
habillement et son franc-parler mon
entrée en politique on a focus
un collectif parmi les solidaires jugés
plus fiscale crée aussi des querelles
internes le parti doit rappeler des
membres à l'ordre pour retrouver
l'harmonie la maison est en ordre Québec
solidaire après si le gouvernement de
reconnaître la crise du logement ça
coûte combien logement à Montréal et sur
l'urgence climatique Québec a interdit
l'exploitation d'hydrocarbure est misé
sur la filière batterie ou l'énergie
verte ce qui lui a valu un important
contrat d'exportation d'hydroélectricité
avec l'État de New York l'urgence
pragmatique c'est ça notre approche les
parties d'opposition on identifie pas
seulement l'environnement comme son
point faible
l'accès aux services de garde en étant
un autre ça ne fonctionne plus les 51
000 enfants sur la liste d'attentes
obligent le gouvernement à mettre plus
d'énergie sur les CPE que les
maternelles 4 ans qui sont finalement
plus difficiles que prévu à réaliser
lors du redressement national en
éducation au Sony Québec
des enseignants abolir les élections
scolaires et transformer les commissions
en centre de service tout semble éclipsé
par les problèmes de ventilation et de
vétusté des écoles un enjeu que les
parties d'opposition lui rappelle sans
relâche
je suis arrivé à la conclusion dans ma
réflexion que l'avenir n'était pas au
Parti québécois avec trois députés sur
10 devenu indépendants le Parti
québécois a perdu son statut de deuxième
opposition après le départ fracassant de
Catherine Fournier Harold Lebel se fait
arrêter pour agression sexuelle et
Sylvain Roy ne s'entend pas avec le
nouveau chef non élu Paul Saint-Pierre
playmondon il y a un seul parti qui peut
battre la claque c'est nous un optimisme
rabrouillé par le ténor Lucien Bouchard
qui qualifie le PQ de véhicules
usé
allez-vous travailler monsieur Legault
donc à faire battre monsieur Trudeau
lors de la prochaine élection on va voir
d'abord comment Monsieur Trudeau va
évoluer
avec Justin Trudeau ne cesse de se
détériorer québécois a obtenu la
nomination d'un juge à la Cour suprême
mais demande toujours des pouvoirs en
matière d'immigration et des transferts
en santé sans succès c'est sûr
qu'on ait différents le Premier ministre
a
aussi que ça député
classe
aujourd'hui je me sens délivrer on va
prendre une courte pause l'ancien
animateur de droite et populaire dans la
capitale nationale qui attend encore le
troisième lien
Eric Duhem se nourrit du mécontentement
il milite pour les libertés
individuelles qui est à garder un
candidat anti-avortement dans ses rangs
en 35 ans de métiers André l'horloger du
Parlement n'avait jamais vu 5 parties se
faire la lutte décidément les temps
changent à Québec
[Musique]